[Musique]
un Français sur deux serait aujourd'hui
malade de l'alcool avec son cortège
d'ennuis médicaux psychologique ou
sociaux certains s'en sortent deviennent
abstinents et témoignent comme dans ce
documentaire signé par Marie Agostini
même si nous venons aussi de le
comprendre avec ce film pour se délivrer
de cette addiction rien ne semble jamais
totalement acquis de quoi s'interroger
sur l'enjeu de santé publique constitue
encore et toujours l'alcoolisme dans
notre pays et c'est ce que nous allons
faire maintenant avec nos invités
présents sur ce plateau de débat doc
aujourd'hui avec vous pour commencer
claire tout ça bienvenue et vous êtes
autrice ancienne journaliste et grands
porteurs vous avez été alcoolique une
pathologie une addiction que vous
racontez d'ailleurs dans un livre
intitulé sans alcool et publié chez
Flammarion votre deuxième ouvrage et
cette fois un roman qui vient lui aussi
de sortir chez Flammarion il s'intitule
féminin merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation pour ce débat dock avec le
professeur amine également bienvenue
merci vous êtes psychiatre addictologue
et chef du service de psychiatrie et
d'addictologie de l'hôpital Paul Brousse
vous êtes aussi président de la
Fédération Française d'adictologie et
auteur de ce livre Comment l'alcool
détruit la jeunesse la responsabilité
des lobbies et des politiques c'est un
ouvrage disponible chez Albin Michel et
puis enfin avec nous Myriam sa vie
bienvenue à vous vous êtes responsable
du plaidoyer de l'association addiction
France addiction au pluriel
reconnu pour son expertise sur le risque
alcool vous y observez à titre personnel
notamment de près les stratégies
déployées par les lobbies de l'alcool
pour affaiblir les orientations de la
politique publique de santé on va bien
sûr et revenir dans cette émission et
puis votre association a tout juste 150
ans cette année je me tourne d'abord
vers vous après ce ce documentaire c'est
formidable témoignage à visage découvert
et c'est pas si courant lorsqu'on parle
d'alcoolisme en France est-ce que vous
êtes reconnu à travers les témoignages
que nous avons entendu tout au long de
ce documentaire je crois que quand on
est addict on se reconnaît toujours dans
la parole des autres addicts parce qu'il
y a des mêmes si on est très différent
on a des parcours un peu communs c'est
horrible mais l'addiction quelque part
ça rejoint ça regroupe certaines
personnes malgré la classe malgré
beaucoup de choses donc oui je me suis
reconnue dans certaines paroles
j'ai vu beaucoup de courage et beaucoup
de force parce que j'avais déjà observé
aux alcooliques anonymes en fait ce
parcours de personnes qui veulent s'en
sortir et au-delà de d'être victime ou
d'être malade je trouve qu'il y a
vraiment ça en fait il y a même dans les
difficultés cette envie de s'en sortir
on le voit à la fin ensemble en fait on
discutant en trouvant des solutions
les Alcooliques Anonymes
ce sont ces thérapie de groupe
auxquelles vous avez assisté et dont on
a vu un certain nombre d'exemples c'est
ces échanges entre groupes
ça ça a été assez déterminant dans
l'articulation je trouve que la parole
enfin l'écriture aussi pour ma part mais
la parole c'est ce qui marche mieux
communiquer avec d'autres personnes qui
sont atteintes de cette maladie enfin
échanger sur des parcours je trouve que
c'est très fort moi c'est ce qui m'a le
plus aidé et quand j'ai été aux
alcooliques anonymes on m'a beaucoup dit
moi aussi au-delà des parcours de santé
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'important
le soutien des autres aussi des figures
des modèles qui puissent vous aider et
ainsi vous pouvez vous dire je suis pas
le seul parce que souvent il y a une
honte derrière l'alcoolisme derrière
c'est derrière l'addiction en fait et
plus on voit des personnes qui ont notre
parcours puis on discute avec eux et moi
on sent seul est-ce que vous trouviez
des points communs
lorsque vous assistiez à ces thérapies
de groupe entre les différentes
personnes qui qui parlaient dans ces
réunions de groupe je crois que je me
suis beaucoup reconnue dans le parcours
de certaines femmes parce qu'il y a chez
les femmes à une façon de boire alors je
vais pas j'en rêve vraiment la façon de
boire mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
on boit pour plusieurs raisons on boit
pour des raisons enfin pour des
problèmes qu'on rencontre de façon
intime mais aussi des problèmes qu'on
rencontre dans sa vie et chez les femmes
c'est toujours un peu les mêmes en fait
c'est la charge mentale c'est les
injustices qu'elles vivent c'est
beaucoup de choses comme ça et donc j'ai
pu me retrouver dans des parcours de
femmes parfois de 100 ans qu'il y avait
des métiers complètement différents des
miens et en même temps on avait le même
désir les mêmes ambitions qui parfois
ont été contrarié et donc c'était
intéressant de croiser encore une fois
les chemins et des parcours avec
d'autres personnes qui n'avaient rien à
voir avec moi et je pense que c'est ça
aussi là
vous trouviez dans l'alcool une une
force pour vous émanciper en tant que
femme en fait c'est un peu un symbole
c'est quelque chose qu'on a construit à
travers les séries bénédiction à travers
une sorte d'imaginaire l'alcool
permettrait d'être plus viril pour les
hommes et pour les femmes ce serait un
espèce de territoire à conquérir pour
peut-être s'émanciper en fait d'ailleurs
toutes les femmes qui s'émancipent dans
les séries dans les films on le voit en
fait en général elles boivent
moi peut-être qu'il y avait de ça il y
avait aussi beaucoup de souffrance je
pense et on le voit par exemple dans le
commentaire il est question d'estime de
soi de te destruction en fait pour le
coup ça signifie féminin et masculin
c'est je pense c'est très propre aux
personnes qui boivent et c'est un reflet
aussi de la souffrance et du mal-être
social en fait parce que c'est à la fois
un parcours intime mais c'est à la fois
quelque chose qu'on subit en fait et qui
est lié aussi à une tristesse une dureté
ambiante on va voir un juste un extrait
du documentaire
avant d'en parler ensemble juste après
me concernant lorsqu'un médecin avec des
mots simples m'a expliqué que c'était
une maladie le déclic s'est fait dans ma
tête
j'avais honte donc j'étais sur la morale
la femme qui boit c'est pas beau l'homme
c'est un peu plus beau on va dire mais
tant que j'avais pas compris que c'était
une maladie j'avais la honte et la honte
m'empêcher de me soigner
Laurence collet côté pardon addictologue
mais qui a choisi dessus des études
d'addictologie après avoir été
alcoolique elle-même et qu'il a anime
ses groupes de prise de parole
est-ce qu'elle nous dit est-ce qu'elle
nous rappelle ce qui est essentiel me
semble-t-il c'est qu'on a bien à faire à
une maladie et ça assez récent
finalement c'est assez récent longtemps
et quand on voit l'histoire de
l'alcoologie ou bien des personnes
malades d'alcool elles ont très souvent
été avant tout condamnés par la société
et juger pour un vice pour des
perturbateurs du lien social et il en
reste encore des choses à la société
finalement montre du doigt ce qui est
sans alcoolique et c'est toujours
l'autre qui est plus alcoolique que moi
et c'est comme ça qu'on se définit on
définit ça comment et c'est tout le
problème de la France la normalisation
d'alcool ou la dénomalisation c'est la
grande question on en est là et
l'avènement finalement de la recherche
en matière d'alcool pas que de la
recherche scientifique pure mais aussi
de l'épidémiologie des statistiques et
de la sociologie a permis finalement de
sortir de la honte et de donner un nom
pour pouvoir finalement traiter les
personnes et ça a été dit par ma
collègue le document il est prise de
conscience qu'on a bien à faire une
maladie c'est très important
d'avoir un élément de motivation et ça
déstigmatise c'est pas gagné c'est pas
gagné mais c'est beaucoup ça permet à la
société de se redéfinir vis-à-vis d'un
phénomène qui est le phénomène de
l'alcool on a du chemin en France et ça
permet aux personnes qu'on sont victimes
finalement de se sentir comme étant des
personnes malades
beaucoup de personnes choisissent de
dire qu'elles sont déprimées anxieuses
elles ont des problèmes que de dire
qu'elles sont alcooliques parce que
l'alcoolisme n'est pas une maladie c'est
un vice et donc ça c'est très important
pour pouvoir accéder à une démarche de
soins et pouvoir aller taper à la porte
de ce qui peuvent nous aider parce que
le problème d'alcool c'est quoi c'est
qu'on y vient très tardivement et
lorsque la maladie s'installe et le plus
important et puis la question est posée
par l'émission C'est à quel moment les
pouvoirs publics vont nous aider à
éviter de rentrer dans leur spirale de
la maladie chronique ma collègue l'a dit
maladies chroniques invalidante et
mortelle évidemment à la fin à la fin
c'est tout ça qui pose de problème de
l'alcool comme débat de société et ce
qu'avec l'alcoolisme on a affaire à une
addiction qui révèle des particularités
par rapport aux autres formes
d'addiction possible je pense à la
drogue notamment au jeu pourquoi pas au
sexe oui à une particularité ça tue et
42000 personnes qui meurent directement
l'alcool en France une autre
particularité c'est qu'elle touche un
système
lorsqu'une personne est alcoolique elle
va finalement impacter le système dans
lequel elle vit son travail sa famille
son conjoint ses enfants
elle va impacter un autre système sa
personne sa personne psychologique sa
personne physique l'alcool détruit des
viscères qui me passent souvent le cas
d'autres addictions donc c'est quelque
chose qui qui a un effet impactant mais
dans l'environnement et ça coûte cher à
la société ça coûte plus cher que ça ne
rapporte contrairement ce qu'on peut
évidemment entendre parti par là donc
c'est vraiment une maladie gravissime au
sens
systémique du terme un Français sur 10
est malade de l'alcool environ
aujourd'hui en France en découle pour 5
millions de Français des ennuis vous
l'avez dit à la fois
médico-psychologique sociaux
49.000 personnes meurent de l'alcool
aujourd'hui chaque année en France et la
France est le sixième pays le plus
buveur
consommateur d'alcool au monde sont les
Danois qui sont les plus consommateurs
dans le monde aujourd'hui c'est dire
l'ampleur tout de même du problème
auquel les pouvoirs publics doivent
faire face aujourd'hui et une auquel
doit faire face une association comme la
vôtre oui et on parle là aujourd'hui des
malades alcooliques mais il y a aussi
tous les buveurs excessifs et en fait
avant d'être alcoolique on est d'abord
un buveur puis un buveur excessif et
ensuite on peut tomber dans l'addiction
à la dépendance et donc c'est important
aussi de ce que disait amine Benyamina
d'être vraiment dans la prévention et
donc comment est-ce qu'on s'assure qu'on
met en place des politiques de santé qui
vont permettre de réduire le nombre
global de consommateurs le mot niveau
moyen de consommation pour éviter que
des personnes tombent ensuite dans la
dépendance parce que le chemin il est
pas d'un côté on a des personnes qui
sont alcooliques et puis de l'autre il y
a les consommateurs d'alcool pour qui
tout va bien et qui n'auront jamais de
problème non non on est bien sur un
système global avec des personnes qui
peuvent tomber dans la dépendance et
puis des personnes qui ont une
consommation excessive qui va avoir une
une des conséquences pour leur santé
sans pour autant qu'elles ne tombent
jamais dans la diction mais ça vient un
coup pour la société il est important
qu'on ait des politiques qui en face
puissent répondre et éviter d'être dans
la valorisation extrême de l'alcool ce
qu'on a encore beaucoup en France et ce
qui explique que la France soit le
sixième plus gros consommateur dans le
monde d'alcool la frontière est parfois
très tenue entre consommateurs et et
addict finalement et il a fallu que
quand même santé publique France et
l'Institut national du cancer et d'abord
de nouveaux repères de consommation
dites à moindre risque donc l'alcool
c'est maximum deux verres par jour
plutôt pour les femmes trois verres pour
les hommes divers par semaine avec des
jours dans cette même semaine sans
alcool voilà
limite qui a été tracé la nouvelle
limite tracée par santé publique France
et l'Institut national du concert ça
vous paraît une limite
sensée raisonnable c'est
l'illustatistique et limite pour pouvoir
donner des idées mais avec ce que vous
venez de citer Jean-Pierre on peut être
malade
est-ce que je veux dire moi j'ai des
personnes qui boivent cette console
cette quantité pour des raisons qui leur
appartiennent parce qu'il y a des
vulnérabilités différentes elles font
une séance du foie
donc ça c'est important pourquoi je dis
ça parce que très souvent les patients
viennent me voir ils me disent voilà en
gros il perçoivent cela comme une
prescription non non ce sont des seuils
pour pouvoir donner une idée pour se
situer c'est jusqu'à deux verres par
jour sachant que ne pas boire c'est
toujours mieux pour la santé et après on
a un risque acceptable qui est jusqu'à
deux verres par jour quand est-ce que
vous êtes rendu compte que vous aviez
dépassé la limite est-ce que vous en
êtes rendu compte par vous-même est-ce
que ce sont vos proches qui vous ont dit
un moment attention peut-être est-ce que
tu dépasses une limite peut-être que tu
es accro à l'alcool en fait ce qui est
intéressant c'est que moi mon livre
justement s'il a autant plu c'est qu'il
parle de cette alcoolisme qu'on
considérait pendant longtemps comme
mondain et en fait qui était un
alcoolisme qui était Captur était
accepté parce que en fait il se comment
dirais il a un aspect festif
à dire mais en fait il correspond aussi
à un alcool un peu plus bourgeois c'est
à dire que c'est pas de type qui va au
PMU à 8h du matin c'est pas l'alcool
précaire c'est pas l'alcool qu'on voit
dans la rue et c'est un alcool qui va
être très répandu et moi j'ai dit ben en
fait j'ai cet alcool là depuis 20 ans ça
a détruit ma vie mais c'est d'une façon
plus laver peut-être de moins
spectaculaire mais peu à peu et en fait
je suis alcoolique et c'est vrai que
beaucoup de gens
m'ont dit à moi j'ai pas réalisé que
c'était ça parce qu'en fait quand on il
y a plein d'adjectifs en fait on est bon
vivant en France il y a une
survalorisation comme ça de l'alcool
excessif qui fait qu'on se rend jamais
compte en fait qu'on est alcoolique
qu'on a des problèmes d'alcool en tout
cas alors que les problèmes sont tout
aussi problés enfin il y a autant tout
autant de problèmes sur votre vie
même si vous buvez deux verres 3 verres
tous les soirs depuis 20 ans que vous
mettez dans des étapes pas possible des
soirées en fait c'est plus festif en
fait c'est un problème et ça beaucoup de
gens ont du mal à l'identifier et je
pense que c'est ce qui a pu dans mon
livre c'est que vraiment je disais bah
voilà moi je suis pas j'ai pas la tête
de l'emploi parce qu'on imaginait un
alcoolique qui forcément et une engager
etc mais j'ai des problèmes d'alcool
parce qu'on distingue plusieurs types
d'alcoolisme aussi l'alcoolisme mondain
on vient d'en parler l'alcoolisme
fonctionnel et puis l'alcoolisme
chronique qu'il a
j'imagine nécessite une intervention
et donc ils arrivent à un stade où il y
a les dommages sont installés et donc on
travaille avec des personnes qui
par finalement arrive chez nous en
revanche ce que ce que vient de citer
claire c'est qu'on a à faire là c'est un
alcool qui est autorisé mais qui est
encore plus perditieux parce que on est
dans un déni partagé et donc on sent pas
la nécessité de venir se soigner puisque
à priori on consomme moins ou un peu
plus que celui que l'on voit tous les
jours et qui reste inséré mais qui part
par ailleurs et dans une prison parce
que s'abstenir deux trois jours devient
compliqué et donc à tout le tout le jeu
du déni qui se met en place on dit je ne
suis pas sous les ponts je n'ai pas
perdu ma femme ni mon mari ni compagnon
mes enfants j'ai pas de problème de
santé je n'ai pas mon bilan biologique
n'est pas mauvais et c'est globalement
et ce qui est triste la grande majorité
de ceux qui ont des problèmes qui
s'ignorent sont plus nombreux finalement
que ce qui viennent pousser la porte
pour se faire soigner justement qui sont
ceux qui viennent pousser la porte de
votre association on a un profil
aujourd'hui qui se dégage entre les
tranches d'âge les hommes les classes
sociales alors on n'a pas un profil on
n'a pas un profil type en plus
l'addiction France intervient sur toutes
les addictions aussi l'alcool est quand
même très présent parce qu'en plus il y
a des polyconsommation donc quand on
boit de l'alcool on fume peut-être aussi
on fume du cannabis l'alcool n'est pas
la première addiction en France je crois
que c'est la cigarette la première
addiction en France en revanche nous
sommes plus consommateurs d'alcool il y
a plus de consommateurs
d'alcool que de que de fumeurs de tabac
et donc les personnes que nous voyons
chez nous alors ça reste beaucoup quand
même quand même assez masculin plutôt
entre
30 et 50 ans parce qu'en fait chez
certaines populations par exemple chez
les femmes c'est beaucoup plus difficile
en fait parce que peut-être ça prend
plus de temps et on arrive elles
viennent moins chez nous donc faut aller
les chercher aller aller les trouver et
parfois donc on mène des consultations
chez des médecins généralistes pour
justement arriver à les rencontrer et
donc on a des personnes qui sont
clairement dans l'alcoolo dépendance et
puis il y a des personnes qui se posent
des questions donc qui ont des grosses
consommations qui sont pas pour autant
complètement dépendants mais qui ont
quand même du mal un petit peu à s'en
passer et donc leur objectif ça va pas
être forcément l'abstinence mais ça va
être déjà d'arriver à maîtriser sa
consommation et donc on va travailler
avec elle et puis des fois il y a des
personnes qui disent bah non pour moi
c'est plus simple d'arrêter complètement
parce que j'arrive pas à maîtriser ma
consommation et donc je préfère je
préfère tout arrêter donc on a vraiment
des des profils très différents et et
l'idée de l'accompagnement qu'on propose
dans nos centres c'est de vraiment
travailler avec la personne avec son
besoin et puis de travailler à la fois
sur les conséquences de sa consommation
de son addiction mais aussi les causes
et donc on a un accompagnement qui est
sur le plan social sur le plan
psychologique et puis évidemment sur le
plan sanitaire pour gérer les
conséquences sur la santé de l'addiction
et il est dit quelque part aussi dans ce
documentaire par l'une des personnes qui
témoigne que c'est un produit formidable
alcool parce que il est disponible on
l'a sous la main tout de suite et puis
il fait il fait effet très rapidement
c'est aussi la sensation que vous avez
eue avec le recul c'est à dire que en
France partie du piège c'est à dire
qu'en France on est encouragé à boire de
l'alcool dès qu'on est jeune en fait on
se construit on se construit socialement
comme ça on nous encourage
tout au long de notre vie pour
socialiser en fait stabiliser en fait et
puis n'est pas français c'est des qui ne
boit pas etc et puis
[Musique]
et contributeurs pardon de notre balance
commerciale alors là c'est c'est
considérable et c'est pour ça qu'il est
aussi disponible l'alcool parce que bien
c'est des forces de notre pays une force
économique une puissance économique
importante est-ce que c'est pas là que
commence les problèmes lorsqu'on prétend
lutter contre l'alcoolisme en France
est-ce qu'il y a pas une forme
d'hypocrisie a commencé du côté des
pouvoirs publics pour lutter contre
l'alcoolisme en France avec ce que
représente
l'alcool est surtout le vin dans notre
pays lutter je n'irai pas jusque là
on lutte contre le tabac on augmente le
prix du tabac on a des vrais campagnes
en intervient en amuse les lobbies c'est
pas le cas et on a moins mais on a
pratiquement plus de manufacture de
tabac en plus absolument ce n'est pas le
cas en France en France lorsque on met
en place une politique entre guillemets
agressif vis-à-vis de l'alcool on est
rapidement hors-jeu
à parler lobbies organisé c'est que la
France est un pays dans lequel vous avez
du vin dans toutes les régions sauf dans
le Nord où vous avez de la bière donc on
est sur on a en France comme des
personnes on est dans une enceinte qui
s'appelle l'Assemblée nationale dans
laquelle vous avez beaucoup de
parlementaires organisant lobby en
fraternelle en
coopérative en quelque sorte pour
défendre les intérêts de la viticulture
ici à la au Sénat dans les cabinets
c'est organisé de cette manière parce
que et les 500 000 emplois que
représente l'agriculture on peut directe
ou indirecte représente le vin en France
donc on en est là et donc les politiques
de santé de prévention qui n'ont pas
pour but de détruire la filière mais
d'alerter sur les risques sont quasi
inexistantes je prends un exemple ça
fait des années les associations comme
indices en France mais pas que essaie de
lutter pour pouvoir augmenter la taille
du pictogramme de la femme enceinte dans
les dans les emballages alcool on y
arrive pas
imaginez si on se met à essayer de de
pousser ce qu'on essaie de faire
évidemment on fait chou blanc euh les
taxes les prix comme l'ont fait des pays
qui avait des problèmes qui sont arrivés
faire arriver à le faire comme les
courses avec le whisky autant dire c'est
un rêve absolu et s'il y a bien un sujet
sur lequel il n'y a pas de clivage entre
les colorations politiques c'est bien
l'alcool vous aurez toujours la
puissance du lobby qui à la pour le coup
qui traverse les colorations politiques
pour pouvoir défendre une filière qui
n'est pas combattue par la médecine et
encore moins par le la science ni les
associations mais l'idée c'est de
dénormaliser on n'y arrive pas addiction
France lutte contre ces lobbies
j'imagine confirmer ce qui vient d'être
dit il y a peut-être des des exemples
qui viennent en tête la doit référence
dans l'esprit de beaucoup de gens
aujourd'hui encore c'est l'aloeva pour
interdire la publicité mais qu'est-ce
qu'il en reste de cette loi aujourd'hui
elle a été détricotée en grande partie
par les lobbies c'est la vérité oui mais
c'est la bonne question qu'est-ce il
reste aujourd'hui de la loi Eva 30 ans
après alors il en reste quand même
quelque chose parce que si on va à
l'étranger on voit bien que les
publicités sont quand même pas les mêmes
mais on voit une évolution quand même
entre le cadre de la loi de 1991 et les
publicités que nous voyons aujourd'hui
où on voit apparaître des personnes sur
la publicité alors que c'était
totalement interdit en 1991 parce que
petit à petit non seulement en détricote
la loi et en plus dans la manière dont
elle est appliquée on grignote quand je
dis on en fait c'est les c'est les
marques d'alcool les industriels qui
grignotent avec des campagnes
publicitaires toujours qui vont toujours
un peu plus loin et qui même si nous
addictions France on agit et on agit en
justice on gagne pas toujours parce
qu'il y a aussi un travail à faire
auprès des magistrats pour faire prendre
conscience aussi parce que c'est
vraiment la question aussi de de on a
parlé tout à l'heure du de la honte de
l'alcool et aussi un tabou autour de ça
une méconnaissance et donc et bien sûr
cette question de ce qu'on voit sur la
publicité des personnes que l'on voit
sur la publicité
euh on voit que on a commencé en 2005
avec une publicité pour du vin on voyait
des viticulteurs on a attaqué cette
publicité on a malheureusement perdu
puisque ben c'était des viticulteurs et
donc on a dit bah ça fait partie en fait
ça rentre dans le cadre de la loi et
petit à petit c'est viticulteurs sont
transformés en bartender et puis de plus
en plus loin et là aujourd'hui on a des
campagnes de publicité par affichage ou
clairement on voit des personnes qui
sont dans la convivialité alors que
c'est théoriquement interdit par la loi
donc il y a la question de la loi et
puis aussi comment ensuite elle est
appliquée et là il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de travail à faire et malheureusement
nous addiction France nos moyens sont un
peu limités pour arriver à à regarder
toute toutes les stratégies marketing on
parlait des jeunes aujourd'hui
pardonnez-moi je vous coupe mais qui a
une véritable politique publique de
prévention contre l'alcoolisme en France
digne de ce nom ou les lobbys sont-elles
aujourd'hui le biloko vous l'avez dit
lobby des marques que cette politique et
inapplicable ou qu'il est très compliqué
il y avait un exemple un exemple le défi
de janvier le drive January donc le mois
sans alcool qui donc vient du
Royaume-Uni qui devait être porté en
France par santé publique France et
c'est les viticulteur eux-mêmes par la
voix d'un de leurs représentant qui a
annoncé quelques semaines avant le
lancement de ce mois sans alcool que
cette campagne
n'aurait pas lieu et donc elle serait
annulée par le gouvernement donc
aujourd'hui le défi de janvier il a été
repris par des associations par la
Fédération Française d'addictologie par
addiction France par plein d'autres
acteurs par des villes aussi qui
s'engagent mais on voit bien que la
volonté politique elle a fait défaut et
donc il faut des acteurs associatifs
pour pour y aller votre gare un peu
extérieur par rapport à ce qui est mis
en place pour la prévention contre
l'alcoolisme qu'est-ce que vous diriez
vous par rapport à ce que vous avez pu
observer
j'en parle dans mon livre de ce fameux
parce que je l'écris en 2019 au moment
où janvier siècle a été annulé enfin il
est sorti à ce moment-là je trouvais ça
à fou en fait aussi parce que on voit
bien sur le terrain et on voit bien moi
quand je rencontre des personnes qui qui
ont lu mon livre des jeunes etc qui a
une envie en fait dans des coudre aussi
avec toute cette image génère autour de
l'alcool parce qu'en fait de l'alcool ça
touche à beaucoup de problèmes même au
sein de la jeune génération c'est à dire
le problème du consentement par exemple
en soirée on sait les ravages enfin ça
crée beaucoup de violence l'alcool
l'autodestruction de la destruction de
ses proches on en parlait tout à l'heure
et donc c'est aussi des sujets qui sont
d'actualité aussi du bien-être social
etc donc on voit bien qu'il y a une
envie de changement mais on voit bien
que le gouvernement lui privilégie
plutôt bah son économie en fait et puis
une sorte de culture française un peu
massive
qui était à rester dans le déni et et
ensevelir tous les problèmes que génère
l'alcool dont les violences les
problèmes de violence conjugales etc par
ce côté justement bon vivant et
gastronomie etc je trouve qu'il y a
quand même un équilibre à trouver moi je
suis pas contre le bon vin mais faut
arrêter quand même de se moquer c'est à
dire que le nombre de personnes qui ont
des problèmes la violence que génère le
coût que ça a il y a un moment donné en
fait il faut agir il y a rien qui est
fait moi ce que je vois c'est des
associations qui se battent mais rien du
niveau au niveau des pouvoirs publics
quoi ou alors une campagne qui a eu je
me rappelle lieu il y a 2 ans je crois
une vague campagne que personne n'a vu
qui est passé un peu sous le tapis
c'est je sais pas c'est très dommage
alors évidemment il faut évoquer des
solutions possibles
pour améliorer cette prévention et
tenter de minimiser cette hypocrisie sur
laquelle vous semblez tous d'accord
autour de ce plateau c'est quoi c'est
l'interdiction pur et simple c'est
sûrement pas non l'interdit c'est le
moteur finalement de la consommation on
le voit avec le cannabis non non ça ne
marche pas non non c'est aussi une
grande forme c'est l'information c'est
l'information c'est ce que vous faites
le doc est formidable parce que on a vu
des gens sincères qui ont témoigné un
visage découvert avec des parcours de
vie comme vous l'avez dit qu'à bossé et
avec rarement des gens qui ont que le
problème d'alcool on voit des émotions
des problématiques psychiques non pas
psychiatriques mais psychologique c'est
un système dans lequel les gens sont en
se retrouvent engloutis et notre travail
c'est de les accompagner nous dans les
structures de soins dans les structures
associatives médico-sociales c'est ce
que l'on fait c'est ça et puis vous
l'avez entendu ma collègue qui a bien
dit au moins la moitié de ces personnes
arrivent à s'en sortir
il y a beaucoup pas fait par exemple il
y a pas de médicaments qui fasse un
miracle qui fasse arrêter de boire c'est
tout le travail de l'accompagnement de
la psychothérapie du médico-social mais
vous nous dites tout de même il y a au
moins la moitié des personnes c'est
formidable en sortir complètement c'est
formidable on a de meilleurs résultats
que beaucoup de spécialités qui sont
évidemment des spécialités d'hypnose de
médecine et puis on le voit pas parce
qu'il y a encore la confusion entre
finalement le vice et la vertu mais on a
affaire un produit particulier
il calme il excite il est accessible il
est facile
il a un effet rapide il a une culture
autour et n'a pas besoin de prescription
est-ce que vous avez un médicament ou le
cocktail est terrible le cocktail est
terrible et avec une politique de
prévention inexistante
si on parle de prévention il faut agir
sur l'environnement il y a trois
facteurs clés qui vont m'encourager la
consommation la publicité on en a parlé
aujourd'hui la publicité auprès des
jeunes c'est sur les réseaux sociaux via
les influenceurs il y a vraiment un
enjeu à encadrer cette pratique qui est
en plein essor par exemple drinking
c'est à dire on boit très rapidement
pour avec un maximum d'effets et puis on
se filme pour le mettre immédiatement
sur les réseaux sociaux à commencer par
Tik Tok et Instagram aujourd'hui ça
effectivement on peut peut-être
s'interroger je vous ai coupé en
publicité le prix en jouant sur la
fiscalité alors c'est vrai que dans un
contexte actuel d'inflation c'est un
petit peu compliqué mais quand même on
parlait du vin tout à l'heure et ben le
vin est très très peu taxé en France en
comparaison à d'autres alcools comme les
spiritueux ou la bière dans d'autres
pays c'est l'inverse parce qu'ils
veulent par exemple en Écosse ils ont
voulu promouvoir le whisky donc c'était
le whisky qui était moins un taxé et
puis parce que le prix a été réellement
efficace concernant les cigarettes il
semble que ça soit le levier majeur pour
lutter contre le tabagisme aujourd'hui
l'augmentation des prix troisième point
et le troisième c'est l'accessibilité
donc ce qu'on voyait dans le reportage
est-ce que disait claire on arrive au
supermarché et on peut acheter très
facilement de l'alcool et même quand on
est mineur on achète très facilement de
l'alcool on a fait une étude à
l'addiction France où on a testé on a
fait du testing et donc dans plus de 90%
des cas des mineurs pouvaient acheter de
l'alcool à la caisse du magasin c'est
considéré mais l'accessibilité comment
est-ce qu'on pourrait contrôler
l'accessibilité l'accessibilité
concernant faudrait distinguer les les
acheteurs les acheteuses là ça semble
très compliqué de contrôler
l'accessibilité l'âge tout simplement
vous allez aux États-Unis ou bien dans
des pays où la loi est strictement
respectée on vous demande bien identité
puis aussi des systèmes ou dans les
supermarchés l'alcool est dans des
endroits qui sont moins accessibles ils
sont pas forcément caché mais en tout
cas on sait pas derrière la caisse c'est
pas on vous on arrive et en fait on est
obligé de passer par le rayon parce que
il y a toujours des promotions en tête
de gondole avec de l'alcool à acheter
donc ça peut être mis à l'écart dans les
magasins il y a des certains pays
notamment les pays d'Europe du Nord qui
font cela et on a des pays aussi ou
carrément on peut pas acheter de
l'alcool en grande surface il faut aller
dans les magasins spécialisés je crois
que c'est le cas de la Suède d'ailleurs
ce qu'on a absolument vous avez un
exemple en tête là où l'autre avant que
je revienne vers vous
d'une politique de prévention en la
matière réussie réellement réussi de par
le monde
un pays de référence en matière de
prévention contre l'alcoolisme
voilà au niveau de l'Union européenne on
a l'Estonie qui a énormément travaillé
sur le sujet avec une politique vraiment
très stricte en matière de publicité qui
ont ils ont augmenté les ils ont
augmenté les prix ils ont réduit
l'accessibilité des produits donc
vraiment une vraie volonté politique
avec la limite donc ils ont mixé en
réalité un peu les trois critères dont
vous connaissez il faut toujours mixer
les trois
mixer des trottes vous en êtes sorti
aujourd'hui
oui mais c'est un combat tous les jours
d'ailleurs les gens le disent dans le
documentaire après moi mon travail est
situé autre part c'est plutôt de déconse
enfin c'est il est complémentaire c'est
de déconstruire un peu l'imaginaire
c'est à dire que c'est un peu on a
commencé à fumer parce qu'il y avait le
cowboy Malboro l'alcool elle incarne
aussi une forme de liberté comme ça il y
a un truc derrière de l'écrivain maudit
etc et moi j'essaie de construire des
personnages par exemple qui sont
puissants de femmes sans boire qui sont
sobre par exemple c'est à dire que au
lieu d'interdire et je pense pas que ce
soit une bonne idée non plus du tout
mais plutôt valoriser aussi la sobriété
ou la modération
déconstruire tout ce qu'on a mis
derrière l'alcool parce qu'on met
beaucoup de choses à l'alcool on est
drôle parce qu'on boit on est puissant
parce qu'on voit et dire bah non c'est
pas vrai en fait ce qui est puissant
c'est d'être intelligent ce qui est
puissant c'est de pouvoir agir d'être
heureux etc sans rentrer dans le
puritanisme n'a rien à voir au contraire
encore une fois déconstruire le mythe de
l'alcool et valoriser d'autres
possibilités en fait pour les jeunes par
exemple je trouve que c'est hyper
important
et donc voilà mon combat il est
personnel mais il est aussi autour de
moi puisque j'en parle souvent beaucoup
de gens viennent m'en parler et j'essaye
de de changer un peu le visage de
l'alcool en tout cas votre lit va fait
bouger quelques lignes et c'est déjà
j'imagine très satisfaisant en ce qui
vous concerne après l'épreuve que vous
avez vécu c'est la fin de cette émission
merci vraiment à tous les trois merci à
participer pour parler aujourd'hui de
cette lutte contre l'alcoolisme après ce
formidable documentaire c'est formidable
témoignage encore une fois un visage
découvert concernant ce sujet qu'on a pu
voir dans dans ce film aujourd'hui vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc
bien sûr sur Twitter merci à sel massali
qui comme à la coutumée m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission et puis moi je
vous donne tout simplement rendez-vous
pour un prochain débat doc et ça sera
bien sûr avec son documentaire et son
débat à bientôt
[Musique]